are you an entertainment or in education
if you're in entertainment the
monetization methods or ad Revenue
patreon Community Support crowdfunding
essentially brand sponsorships whereas
if your education the opportunities I
believe are more it's also possible to
make more money with a much smaller
audience before you start adding more
things to your plate I think trying to
find a leveraged activity that you can
create passive income money coming in
when you're not working that's kind of
how you go to the next level as a
content creator
welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean how you doing today Nolan I am
fired up to be hanging out with you dude
we're gonna talk about money how to make
money what to do when you make money and
uh I'm excited I'm excited it's gonna be
good and I kind of wanted to start off
talking about your personal experience
uh going back to the early days you know
kind of tell me just take me back to
when you made your first 100K kind of
building up to that just what was that
story what did that look like and then
I'm excited to just hear today like what
you do different but tell me tell me the
story of how that happened yeah
um I've heard it said that like making
your first six figures is brutal and
that was my experience I mean the first
year that we generated over a hundred
thousand dollars as independent
contractors basically it's just my wife
and I that were working on it and I was
the main content creator she managed our
personal finances
um was in
2016 however I actually had generated a
six-figure income
the year previous or in 2014 because I
had a almost eighty thousand dollar
salary working at a church and I
generated an actual extra 50 on the side
from mainly freelance work and so I had
a couple maybe an extra three grand a
month in freelance work that's like 36
000 a year plus the 75 I was making so I
crossed the six figure Mark now we were
living in Irvine California and cost of
living was so crazy there we were
actually still losing money from our
savings at the time just because where
you live so it's funny when you throw
these numbers around six figures a year
could be just absolutely crazy if you're
living in a certain area and in some
areas I heard someone in Washington
state say kind of flippantly but I I
think it's somewhat true they're like if
you don't make 150 a year you're like on
the streets yeah I was like I don't know
about the streets but I mean like fair
enough because certain areas whether
it's taxes cost of living housing and
that was the case in Irvine it was rent
was really crazy so when we moved back
to Las Vegas in 2015
it was all freelance clients and then
once those uh kind of transition all in
one month it was all YouTube affiliate
marketing and those were the two things
and it was actually that was the
original vehicle just AdSense or were
you doing anything else with you like uh
affiliate marketing was the bigger thing
so October 2015 think media is 16 000
subscribers ad revenues maybe 50 to 100
a month and Affiliates is 250 to 500 a
month
the year previous Affiliates would
always be as much as a thousand dollars
during the holidays when it was a side
hustle for me because so much online
shopping and I was always as we teach
positioning videos to rank so that
people would click on affiliate links
during the holidays and all this online
spending went up so I always was making
like good extra money especially in Q4
and so when I was transitioning October
2015 I was coming into a really
strategic time November Cyber Monday uh
Black Friday as well as shopping in
December and so I had three main
freelance clients they all basically
fired me in October 2015 so I went all
in on just YouTube and from ad revenue
and Affiliates by January of 2016 I made
four thousand five hundred dollars on
Amazon and AD Revenue was maybe 500
bucks so there's there's five there's 60
Grand a year right there if it was just
Amazon stayed consistent and an ad
Revenue stayed consistent but every
single month it built after that so
moving kind of forward I mean you
started I know you built a course you
started to grow but I'm curious in those
beginning stages especially when
expenses are tight you're not making a
ton of money
were you able to kind of reinvest into
the business like were you taking out
loans to reinvest in the business like
can you explain to me what you were kind
of using the the money we're making for
and and maybe what you do differently
even yeah I mean I think one thing
that's always been cool my wife Sony and
I have always been really unified and I
think we have always lived below our
means and try to be as Frugal as
possible and so I think like the first
time I bought a nice car in my life was
pretty into our business and by a nice
car it was like a two-year-old certified
pre-owned Ford Explorer Sport like that
was like that was like a Ferrari for me
and it was still it was still like being
just a pretty practical so in this time
we have paid off Vehicles so we have no
car payments you know I'm think I'm
driving a a Ford Taurus that I got from
my friend David Goldstein when he
upgraded to a Tesla he said quote me a
number on how much you'd pay for this
and I kind of blue booked it is probably
worth 11 I was like seven Grand he's
like all right and I was like wait a
minute you're just gonna take whatever I
off I mean I mean five like what are you
doing that was a typo yeah and he just
like took literally the first number I'm
like man I should have low balled even
more but we were uh so we had like paid
off cars and then we're in cost of
living in Vegas was we'd moved back to
Vegas partly because the cost of living
it's significantly cheaper than Irvine
so where we're living is a strategic
decision
um in terms of cost as one aspect you
know rent is cheap no car payments and
we're not crazy like we just we I don't
know we live pretty chill lives and so
and and mind you can still love an
amazing life I think if you're down with
that you know Netflix and yeah and so
what was I investing in I had been
investing heavily in my business ever
since probably 2008 and when I say
investing in my business probably the
biggest investment would be myself so I
was whether that meant buy a new camera
or buy a lens or buy a piece of gear
that would help me create content or buy
an online course or buy education or buy
plane tickets to fly to an event
um we would use our money
mainly for that kind of stuff and oddly
enough it's kind of weird that
maybe my counselor says I should get a
different hobby than business but like
business is kind of my hobby like
personal development so my favorite
thing to buy is like books yeah my
favorite thing to buy is like courses
because I just love learning and I do
see a positive Roi related to that or
reinvesting in those things and so and
both Sony and I were willing to
sacrifice for a season so we saw we
understood the season we were in it was
a season of investing in ourselves so I
don't think I would have done much
differently what I would have done
differently
is from losing the freelance clients in
to going uh
you know getting to the the results of 4
500 a month I was still
dividing my attention across multiple
channels and
it was kind of how many channels did you
have kind of a mistake I mean so I'm
doing video influencers with
Benji which was positive because we're
building up towards YouTube Secrets
we're interviewing lots of people
you could see the value in it for a lot
of reasons it was content for the book
it was our education by learning what we
got to interview these individuals it
was personal branding and awareness it
wasn't really profitable
because it those types of videos were
not as directly correlated in that
moment there was no book to sell and
there was no course and AD Revenue
wasn't great on a new channel that
channel was like just starting
where my most profitable videos were me
identifying a topic I could talk about
that was rankable that was connected to
affiliate marketing and I had so
mastered that already that if I just
stopped doing everything else and only
did that
I probably would have made six seven or
eight thousand by January and not forty
five hundred because I was hustling and
spinning my wheels on I even like we did
this tour the video influencers
La Tour and I think Benji couldn't go
and Sonia went and John mediana went and
famebit paid us five grand
to do like five videos and mind you that
five grand was like gas Hotel
like food it was all operations it was
that's not a ton of money and and we
were like we locked in Lewis house uh to
be on the on the video influencer show
by buying some of his school of
greatness books I was like hey if I buy
you know 10 books or something or 25
books and so we were investing and all
that stuff and all of that was
great I would recommend startup
entrepreneurs just be doing massive
actions you know different things but
even that was not the most efficient use
of our time driving to La I mean we're
learning a lot we're building our
Network building relationships but if I
would have sat at home identified
rankable topics you know to the
affiliate marketing thing and that's why
I tell people these days
figure out your shortest path to revenue
it's maybe a hard thing to figure out
but like what is the shortest path to
revenue what are the income producing
activities related that are best for
your Niche or your topic identify those
and stop doing everything else as a
creative I liked I mean again it was
sort of just it's fun to follow
opportunity but I remember Andre Olivier
from Rivers Church in South Africa was
like hey man can you come out and film
our
um you know new building ceremony and I
was like sounds cool and like the level
of energy it took compared and you know
it's a church they weren't able to pay
us very much money so it was like
financially it was like a losing thing
but I mean I got to go to South Africa I
did film a couple time lapse Tech
there's something media videos out of me
filming a Sunset and and it all of that
stuff I think made me who I am today but
I I for sure invested crazy levels of
energy
and maybe 30 of it was directed towards
income producing activities and 70 of it
was just scatter shot and so if I would
if I would have done something different
it would have been being a little bit
more business-minded and less like
creative Muse minded so if you you're
looking back but I want you to put
yourself in today 2023 and just the
current state of YouTube there's so many
more uh ways even to monetize what would
you do differently in regards to your
time because I think a lot of people
right now you either have you know time
or money and some people you know
they're they're working on the money but
they have some time and like what you're
saying is and I think you know I
definitely uh relate to this I think a
lot of people do it's like you're you
don't have money and then you're wasting
your time doing things that really
aren't bringing the highest Roi for you
so today what are people listening to
this they're like if they only have a
few hours a week is it still affiliate
marketing is it something else where is
it just starting to build the personal
brand they don't have a big Channel yet
like where should they be spending their
time as top priority I think a couple
approaches I think number one in in one
of our past podcasts with Omar I think
one of the best things they could do is
actually spend a few extra hours working
for a successful content creator or
entrepreneur that's doing content so
that they
Fast Track their education
um while learning from somebody who's
got a dialed in process and they can
learn all the pieces of that process
that'd be one way to do it the second
thing to consider would be it depends on
the business model so if it would be
find a YouTube business model that works
that best fits your skill set
so if it's for example you want to be in
gaming and it's kind of a reaction or
maybe it's answering specific questions
like 10 secrets for you know getting
started in Call of Duty or something
it's kind of a search based and you just
kind of can identify that like I this
works and I've gotten to a point where I
can get 22 000 views or 75 000 views or
even 122 000 views I would say this like
if you could figure out how to make
consistently
a hundred thousand viewed videos
easier said than done for listeners but
just follow me out with this like that's
not super crazy
it's a it's not low but it's also not
that high and let's say you can't even
grow then it's a math thing it's just
how consistently can I repeat that video
and that'll add up quick because you do
10 of those in a month it's a million
views that could be two to five thousand
dollars or more depending on the CPM I
was looking at one of our videos that
has a hundred and seventy eight thousand
views and it's got almost five grand for
a hundred and seventy how long was it
two it's a very long video because of
multiple ad spots and I think that's
also uh do you think you know people
should be utilizing eight plus minutes
so people don't know if the video is
eight minutes long you can do a mid-roll
not every time is YouTube gonna show
that person the mid-roll but more than
not there's they're gonna get more ads
and so you can actually that's like an
easy hack you can do to make more money
is that something like people should
even be 100 okay yeah so for a a
business model would be maybe you work
at a tech company and you're a coder and
so then you're like I kind of want to
build side income and so I'm going to go
home and it takes me maybe a week in my
extra hours but I'm gonna put together
these like long form explanational
videos about how to code JavaScript and
they take me some time and I got to put
some Polish in them but when I put out
30 to 45 minutes to like 90 minute
videos I eventually you have enough of
them that boom there you go there's your
eight thousand dollars a month and
you're making six figures from ad
Revenue if that's the model and if you
are an education Camp a channel there's
a lot of ways to make more money quicker
and you should have multiple streams of
income but you can just find one thing
and so if I that's why I look back if I
could focus on the one thing
affiliate marketing isn't even best for
every Niche yeah it is perfect for Tech
because the products are a little bit
more expensive there's an audience for
it if you're clicking on those links
you're also you may not even buy the
camera we recommend but you're going to
buy your USB cable you may buy a
standing desk you're building out your
battle station we sell a lot of random
stuff and we always talk about this how
cool it is that when someone clicks on
an Amazon affiliate link you get credit
for anything they purchase in 24 hours
so there's a lot of weird random stuff
Have You Ever Seen just like a rant like
something right yeah I mean you're
seeing like women's undergarments you're
seeing like weird because you'll get
credit for like Amazon rentals you're
like dude what are you watching and I
don't know this weird sketchy stuff was
on Amazon you know you'll see like baby
products and and food products but then
naturally you also see a lot of things
very related to the channel yeah Tech
stuff Tech stuff we've never recommended
but just Tech in general and so
that model so that I had cracked like I
knew how to identify topics rank videos
optimize videos and I'd built up my
skill sets
and uh so that model would work there
and it could work in other Industries it
worked for my personal Channel last year
in January I didn't post any videos and
I made like two thousand dollars and
that was through affiliate marketing it
maybe was 400 500 in Amazon but where I
made most of my money was like 1500
bucks I had one video that was ranking
and it it was a Lut which is basically
like a color grade like a color preset
and that video and I love it and so I
made a video talking all about it and I
think it's like unless it was like 35
maybe 50 for this like pack this
pack and people would buy it and I have
like a 30
uh like a very high Amazon gives you and
you're from like one to four percent
something low like that so a huge hack
is like if you are in uh whatever Niche
you're in like find it doesn't have to
just be Amazon a lot of people are
sharing just different products and even
digital products where you can make take
way higher percentages and like dude I
was pulling like a thousand bucks for a
couple months not posting videos one
video ranked and then uh I I was able to
just make some passive income that way
even without Amazon what's cool though
is you have a free training
um All About affiliate marketing and so
I know you go much deeper into that so
we're going to cover some other topics
but that's it freethinkclass.com can you
share a little bit about what that
training is and and kind of what people
can get there yeah I think that for 99
of niches you should start with
affiliate marketing you know because you
don't have to create a product of your
own you don't have to be approved for
the Amazon partner program
um you don't have to figure out the
merch thing you don't even need a big
audience so to do like patreon or
Channel memberships
so it's a skill set that should be in
your tool belt even if it's not where
your career Advance is it's where most
people's career should start if they
want to earn extra income on the side
and uh and if they even want to earn
significant income again I was able to
get to six figures doing just YouTube
and affiliate marketing so if yeah if
you want to see that step by step then
that class is definitely
um a must watch have you heard of
ClickBank
yeah you know your thoughts on on that
for YouTubers so ClickBank has kind of
had it's kind of more of an internet
marketing type of website but they have
that's kind of old school affiliate
marketing and it would it'd be the idea
that you could go find a product that
somebody else has created an example
would be though would be like in a
marathon training course
so you have a running Channel or you're
thinking about starting a channel a way
to do affiliate marketing is like you
maybe even have advice but you've never
packaged it in a course and so you could
find like a hundred dollar like a 97
marathon training course on ClickBank
that probably pays 50 percent in terms
of affiliate commission so that's fifty
dollars every time that you make a sale
of that product and so clickbait hosted
a lot of information products which
you'd kind of consider online courses
but it could be bigger than that what's
interesting is one of my videos that
earned over twenty thousand dollars in
its life time was called best greens
juice powder about organifi green juice
and that was actually hosted on
ClickBank they eventually changed like
reversion and a different platform but
that was a ClickBank site so that was
actually a physical product that you mix
with water that kind of had that health
benefits and so um yeah and in that
world though also it was known to get a
little bit sketchy there was things like
jvzoo or ClickBank which is sort of in
that world of people pushing info
products that are maybe a lot of hype
and a lot of fluff a lot of Sizzle no
steak gotcha so you know what's cool
about YouTube today and is different
than when you were you know getting
started making a lot of money is they
have which I love they're just giving
you more and more opportunities to
monetize on the platform like YouTube
memberships are not a thing I think
patreon was at that time
um I'm curious you know why you didn't
decide to do a membership early on I
know eventually uh you got into a
membership thing but today talk about
YouTube merch there's shorts are now
monetized there is uh you know I'd love
to hear your thoughts on merch and
memberships like are those things that
is worth the time for someone who maybe
should they do it once I go full time
should they set it up now and forget
about it you know the I can tell you
where my AI thinking comes from it
doesn't mean the thinking is right but
this is how I think I really am obsessed
with leverage Leverage is a term that
many people probably don't use very
often if you're sitting at the kitchen
table with your family nobody probably
said leverage during that conversation
um can you leverage me the bread to my
right wrong leverage and and sometimes
it kind of does mean like if you were to
use something like my dad I grew up on
six acres and if we need to like move a
stump you would use leverage of some
kind to like you know some metal rod
that you get under there because you're
trying to lift greater than your weight
but here's my understanding of what
leverage means like you're trying to uh
use your time for something that is
going to give you more time in the
future what can I do today that's going
to give me more time in the future and
how much time do I really have and so
the powerful thing about YouTube is it
is kind of like passive income or
investing in real estate you invest in
the real estate today it goes up in
value over time you're leveraging your
money
um you're not trading your time for
[Music]
this video is brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
my hesitancy for doing a membership was
simply because I wanted to count the
cost of as soon as I get people signing
up for this I'm just gonna have to keep
fulfilling on it and I wanted to try to
keep my time in my possession and this
is why I'm obsessed with ranking videos
this is why we have an academy literally
called video ranking Academy because of
Leverage and so not only did I want to
start with making videos that ranked in
search connected to passive income that
also I wasn't shipping the products out
or accepting the returns like I was able
to literally be hands off even if I only
make four percent on Tech
happy because
all I have to do is make the YouTube
video right connect it and optimize it
properly and Amazon will do the work for
me YouTube will do the work for me and
then I wanted to avoid adding more
complexity to my YouTube business and
just make more of those because I was
like if I could do all of this and make
four grand a month if I do this more I
can make eight grand a month the truth
is eventually
I do need to do more I did need to do
more I think eventually your business
evolves and we did evolve into other
things but before you start adding
adding adding adding more things to your
plate I think trying to find a leveraged
activity that you can create passive
income and have
uh money coming in when you're not
working that's kind of how you go to the
next level as a content creator and a
business owner and the cool thing about
YouTube is it gives you a unique
opportunity because a ranked video is
like an employee that you pay once that
works for you for free when you're not
working that'd be leverage you have a
ranked video you made it one month but
next if you because people go how can I
hire how can I even have the time to
think about hiring and interviewing
somebody or figuring it out well you
need leverage you need you need to get
your time back and so ranking videos
gets you your time back because now or
you just need to take a break time off
YouTube has been known to be such a
cause of burnout
because you have to just keep you're the
you're the pedaling bear you just have
to keep going keep posting pushing for
that next viral video and even this is
why I avoided doing brand deals for a
while until we had a system at think
media and even more team to carry the
weight because every time I would get
into it it potentially would take my
attention off of creating the next
leverage thing similarly when I built an
online course that was also a leveraged
activity to some extent you then you
have customer service you got to reply
customers and and you want to make sure
you take care of people which is all
work that should come along with that
but the fact that you can make the
course one time but then sell it
multiple times is a more leveraged
activity than say one-on-one coaching or
something else so that was my personal
Obsession so that's a long answer to
your question of I think you have to
pick what works best for you and in
certain industries and you want to pick
out what what you love doing so what I
would also recommend is I think too many
creators spread their attention to they
hear you should create multiple streams
of income and they're just starting and
they go and here's my business plan I'm
gonna get patreon going I definitely
want to get some merch going I'm
planning two online courses I know I
need to write an ebook and then I want
to get approved for the AdSense program
and I want to do and it's like whoa
you're like spreading your focus across
a lot of different things and you're not
necessarily creating leverage in any of
those because while you still have to go
home and try to write the book that's
not earning for you yet and when you
still have to go home and like fulfill
you have three patreon people but you
made a promise I'm gonna go live and
answer your questions every month well
then you better be there live answering
their questions every month so it's how
many promises are making how much time
are you committing and so before
extending your tent Stakes too soon that
going back to what is the shortest path
to revenue what is the best income
producing activities and if possible how
can those be automated and if you do
YouTube Right YouTube keeps bringing you
views and however whatever you connect
that to it could be clicks on your
course which could bring in sales when
you're sleeping or clicks on your
affiliate links which could bring on
sales when you're sleeping so I think
Leverage is a big concept to study to
understand and to pursue not because and
you could say because of like Hey
passive income so I could chill because
now I just have this money coming in I'm
on vacation all the time like maybe for
a while but like that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying that you have some
passive income coming in so that you can
put better systems in your business get
a team around your business just get
some peace of mind back personally and
work on the next thing or take a break
break guard your mental health and then
be able to be in it for the long haul
Mary's Nest you know spoke recently on
the think media podcast and that uh
episode is in our archives at least on
the YouTube channel for sure it was in
January of 2023 and she um was sharing
how she has a YouTube Partner manager
eventually they reach out to you and
they'll say hey and they'll give you
some advice typically their advice isn't
very profound but they just kind of tell
you about YouTube features and stuff so
she's talking to a girl they connect her
with and this person she's at 800 000
subscribers so she's in like retirement
Legacy years making cooking videos
loving life and her partner manager from
YouTube goes so Mary almost to a million
subscribers she's going to get a go play
button she goes who's your team
like uh how many people do you have on
your team and she goes team it's just me
my husband she's on her way to a million
just her and her husband the reason why
though is she followed what we teach at
video raking Academy and she has so many
videos she's added to her Library over
the years that are bringing in that
revenue and she's like yeah you know
like I'm not going to work around
Father's Day because I want to give I
think her husband edits the videos or
something and she's like I want to give
him the time off because it's Father's
Day so it's that's the other thing that
leverage creates for you is if you're
going to be a solo Creator or a
solopreneur you have you've really
actually created a business because of
the power of YouTube the business is
working for you when you're not working
because of how many videos she's put out
there that have been getting views for
the last four plus years and are
connected to affiliate links or things
and those are her main thing I'm pretty
sure it's basically Affiliates and AD
revenue and then occasionally she does
sponsorships but those two vehicles are
enough for her and her husband to make
an incredible living and have a
sustainable I mean again her energy and
her joy and all that stuff is amazing
but all these creators complaining about
burnout she isn't all these creators
complaining about being worn out she's
fine because she's created a really
healthy Rhythm and created a a Cadence
on YouTube that has allowed her to last
for the Long Haul I love that and I um I
want to kind of end with just like very
practical advice and I love the idea of
of thinking through what what is it that
could really leverage your time and it's
cool because when I think of leveraging
my time I think of hiring out someone to
edit and and that is a great way to
leverage your time but that is a cost
and you know we're talking about making
your first 100K right and so a lot of
times you can do that solo which is
really really cool to hear that story
from Mary's Nest
um before I want to hear you know just
your final thoughts on on what beginners
should be doing one of the things that
comes to mind for me is I know I really
resonate when you started talking about
all the different ideas all the
different options that YouTube gives you
and then beyond that there's just so
much this like how do you choose I think
what you can do is just ask your
community
what do you want and I think it's it's
it's very safe to say that most
YouTubers should be doing obviously turn
on ads so you have your AdSense ones you
get monetized that's great and
everyone's used to that affiliate links
is great you can throw affiliate links
down this even if you're not reviewing
products you can still have affiliate
links in your description on like your
favorite workout gear if you have a
workout Channel but you know there's
ways to do it I think those are great
pieces of advice but if you're going to
build uh some sort of course or
membership or something it's like ask
your audience do they want it and uh and
then and that can bring I think Clarity
to people who are maybe doing too much
it's like maybe your community doesn't
want merch yeah you know maybe they
don't
um and so what what kind of final advice
would you just give to someone looking
to scale maybe just with the
opportunities today I know we didn't
touch on shorts we have a podcast that
people can listen to Deep dive into
shorts but uh when it comes to Brand
deals or other opportunities out there
what would you say kind of the
opportunities to focus on besides you
know some of the ones we talked about
yeah I mean I think that the first thing
you want to decide is are you an
entertainment or in education and if
you're in entertainment it's the
monetization methods are pretty much ad
Revenue
patreon Community Support crowdfunding
essentially
brand sponsorships and those are the
main ones on the entertainment side and
typically you need scale because the
brand sponsorships you do are probably
more broad appeal and Mass Appeal so you
need more viewership and then you want
more viewership for your ads and then
your community supporting you because
they're fans kind of more as the
mentality
whereas if your education
the opportunities I believe are more
it's also possible to make more money
with a much smaller audience you could
have a very small YouTube channel make
big money and so on that side you can
still do ads you could still do brand
sponsorships but on this side you're
creating an online course is a great
idea the the where income really began
to scale at think media was when we
created our first course video ranking
Academy but and one reason for that
is pretty simple it's the fact that when
we create an online course that's our
own intellectual property our own
product
we make I want to say 98 of the revenue
because it takes two percent for the
processing fees and using kajabi they
take no fee of the course
so if Amazon is going to pay you one to
ten percent how much better would it be
to be get 98 and different than when
it's a digital product if you were to
create hard Goods there's a lot of times
margins are low so you sell a hoodie but
it costs you 35 dollars for the hard
cost of the hoodie you have a ten dollar
markup you only make ten dollars it's
fine but you know ten percent twenty
percent thirty percent margins so think
about that so on the education side uh
you have YouTube ads sponsorships but
you can create an online course
affiliate marketing and then a lot of
times events people want to come to
events or coaching or group coaching or
membership sites because for Education
people are actually learning something
and it's actually not that radical
people are familiar with paying for
education to go to college or paying to
go to university
that is just shifting to digital and
e-learning in fact the new data tells us
that by 2028 the e-learning industry is
going to be a 1.2 billion dollar
industry per day
geez 1.2 billion being transacted a day
on e-learning in by 2028 so you're
you're positioning yourself if you
position yourself to help people learn
something teach something and educate
there's massive opportunity but at the
end of the day it's about playing to
your strengths it's about you know
figuring out what is your passion what
are you best at and what is there a
market for and then how you build a
business model around that is predicated
on your strengths your passions what you
ultimately want to do what you're
willing to commit to how much time you
have in the week and so obviously people
should definitely stay connected
subscribe because that's the point of
this podcast is to help people learn the
skills learn kind of the blueprints
learn the different methodologies and
ways of earning a great living in the
crater economy or also and then I mean
number three is leads clients and sales
for your business too and you may be
educating or you may just want to
attract consumers or B2B and you already
have products or services that you're
just looking for leads and clients for
so whatever your end goal is we want to
Define that and then we work backwards
from there to figure out the best way of
monetizing and hitting your financial
targets and I love your training on how
to create an online course even uh
without a following and so you can click
on screen check out that video I think
you guys are going to enjoy it see you
guys in the next video